Now let's see how the definition of
a problem maps onto the root founding
domain.
First, the initial state we're given.
Let's say we start of in Arad.
And the goal test,
let's say that the state of being in
Bucharest is the only state
that counts as a goal.
And all other states are not goals.
Now the set of all the states here
is known as the states space.
And we navigate the states
space by applying actions.
The actions are specific to each city.
So when we're in Arad,
there are three possible actions, to
follow this road, this one, or this one.
And as we follow them we build paths or
sequences of actions.
So just being in Arad is
the path of length zero.
And now we could start
exploring the space and
add in this path of length one.
This path of length one and
this path of length one.
We can add in another path,
here of length two and
another path here of length two.
Here's another path of length two.
Here's a path of length three,
another path of length two, and so on.
Now at every point, we want to separate
the state out into three parts.
First, the ends of the paths,
the farthest paths that have been
explored, we call the frontier.
And so
the frontier in this case consists
of these states and
are the furthest out we can explore.
And then,
to the left of that in this diagram,
we have the explored part of the state.
And then off to the right
we have the unexplored.
So let's write down
those three components.
We have the frontier,
we have the unexplored region,
and we have.
Explored region.
One more thing.
In this diagram, we've labeled the step
cost of each action along the route.
So the step cost of
going between Neamt and
Iasi would be 87, corresponding
to a distance of 87 kilometers.
And then the path cost is just
the sum of the step cost.
So the cost of the path of
going from Arad to Oradea
would be 71 plus 75.